[Música]
repentismo improvisación poética de cima
en cuba se canta con instrumento musical
con orquesta de cuerdas y se bebe ron
aquí se hace a capella y bebiendo agua
vamos a ver cómo son
en el cedex gaditanos
algo raro va a pasar
ha venido a improvisar un repentista
cubano
vine desde muy temprano y me senté en un
rincón
y he visto como un ciclón de gente muy
inteligente me pasaba por el frente
me asustaba el corazón
lo he visto todo lo he oído me he puesto
tanto a pensar que ahora no sé
improvisar
me siento tan conmovido tan asustado ha
tenido que que les voy a decir cómo
ponerme a escribir en el viento lo que
pienso después de un discurso inmenso
que mira hacia el porvenir después de
ver
aveledo
a lucía caro
y ver a javier el gran javier ya todo me
causa miedo esto parece un enredo de
poeta repentista que leyendo con la
vista lo que pretende expresar se
debería callar para ser mejor artista
pero estoy aquí es verdad he traído
hasta una mesa del fondo de mi cabeza
saco con celeridad palabras en cantidad
para que la gente entienda que por más
que yo les venda el arte del repentismo
estoy haciendo ahora mismo una poética
así en la ya david me presento y en este
círculo rojo voy a ver cómo recojo las
palabras que él soltó las recojo si o no
pues yo voy a recoger ya la palabra
javier y el apellido ruibal para saber
que al final puedo también componer un
nombre y un apellido de una manera
alocada y a través de la mirada a
dictarse las al oído para que tenga
sentido que soy improvisador que no soy
presentador y que no soy un cantante
pero que lo hago bastante bien o que
incluso es peor si me quedo allí callado
sentado casi escondido y no le doy al
oído un poema improvisado y ya que estoy
inspirado
a este lugar esta forma de versar con un
público inteligente que mirándome de
frente me comienza a acojonar
la tez de tecnología y la es de
entretenimiento la de diseño siento que
me dictan poesía
la equis de alexis
habría que averiguar con empeño en un
lugar tan pequeño donde tanta luz
penetra porque el peso de mi letras está
estropeando el diseño
se pasó
se pasó mucho trabajo pero si hay una
alternativa la equis antes iba arriba y
ahora se encuentra debajo
debe ser que debe ser un agasajo
al que fue diseñador
da vida el presentador estaba está
preocupado y yo a su lado sentado dije
déjalo es mejor
la sed de cádiz y cuba
la de amor y de amistad la vez de
diversidad la y de ingenio e incuba
la zeta de eso
coadyuva para ayudar al poeta que haya
una fauna completa que pueda ayudar al
hombre y que justifique que justifica
que el nombre de cádiz termina en zeta
la uv de universidad la universidad la n
de no me conviene
la idea interesante tiene bastante
veracidad la de espontaneidad la erre de
revolución la s de solución la y de la
inteligencia la t de la transparencia y
la y de ellos perdón
estos señores ha sido un poema
improvisado y el aplauso que me han dado
tal vez me lo ha merecido o ha sido un
regalo urgido que la gente me está dando
porque estoy improvisando en este
círculo rojo donde hay verbos que recojo
y luego los voy soltando
muchas gracias
muchas gracias repentismo improvisación
poética es un arte que yo aprendí
también con pantalones cortos no les
rompí la guitarra a ningún hermano les
robe las palabras he estado toda la vida
rodando en las palabras a la gente por
eso mi espectáculo se llama ensalada de
palabras con pimienta cada vez que voy
por los colegios con las escuelas
preguntan que como yo digo como palabras
palabras a la plancha palabras crudas
palabras fritas palabras
es calzadas palabras adjetivos
sustantivos proposiciones y los niños
flipas y de la palabra el lenguaje es
una comunidad bastante ecológica así que
eso sí en gotas por dentro o por fuera
y entonces yo me traje a los deberes
hecho por eso traje de la mesa auxiliar
traje las gafas auxiliares y entonces
porque me había pedido
enrique me había venido david que
improvisara con las cosas que habían
pasado aquí delante de mí y entonces
claro son tantas que he tenido que hacer
mi chuleta como un amigo rivas y
bicicleta la había dividido en tres
ensaladas puedo hacer una ensalada hasta
hasta el concierto de magnífico
espectacular de merche corisco y luego
haré una segunda ensalada con la con el
otro grupo de ponentes y luego haremos
una ensalada entre todos los que están
aquí participando ya veré si les sienta
bien
esta ensalada de palabras comienzo
diciendo
me encantan las ensaladas
que presta el vocabulario yo creo que es
necesario que existan otras jornadas
para palabras rimadas con arte y
ecología o sea verdad lo decía
ayúdenme a soñar enséñame a ver el mar
esto sí era poesía este es el
antropoceno es un tiempo sostenible
aunque parezca imposible improvisar es
muy bueno yo muchas veces me lleno de
luz cuando voy andando baños de bosque
buscando para empezar a cambiar reloj de
hielo es de usar para ver si de para ver
cómo y hasta cuándo puede una madre de
sara alimentar al planeta y ayudar a
este poeta que es un repentista oral
casi siempre yo al final busco con la
poesía hacer una cirugía estética en él
en el momento maría dolores yo siento
que eso me presta energía yo busco la
perfección de la cirugía plástica aunque
usan la rima drástica como para la
improvisación el número pi perdón eso sí
no lo entendí
porque a mí el número pi me rebaja la
autoestima y no lo encuentro una rima
que me quede bien aquí pero no importa
mi amiga porque ya lo dijo aveledo que a
nada le tiene miedo el repentista fatiga
el tiempo pero lo obliga a hablar muy
mal del machismo audiovisual ahora mismo
porque alexis díaz pimienta haya pasado
los cuales tos
y eso le da un nerviosismo por el
casting el perfil por las cosas que
sucede y aunque yo improviso adrede me
multiplica por mir no soy guapo ni
gentil ni me encuentro muy delgado tengo
cuenta se habrán dado también el culo
caído
y estoy bastante aburrido fofi sano me
han llamado pero no importa es mejor es
mejor crear desde algún vacío porque
crear es lo mío soy un improvisador lo
dijo con una flor en la cabeza esa chica
que con el arpa me explica las cosas que
va a decir una artista que ha de ir
buscando a quien lo sala salpica de flow
de flujo verbal para que improvise ella
y se convierta en la estrella de este
momento final hay una malla total voy a
caer en la malla para ver si no se calla
para ver si no se calla el poeta que se
queja sin una argolla en la oreja que le
esté dando acá que le esté dando batalla
y todo esto ha sucedido en este mismo
lugar y me ayudó a improvisar me ha
alimentado el oído pero donde ya el
sentido lo perdí
se me desvela y se rompió mi espinela y
hace que me sienta a otro fue cuando
todos nosotros vimos a merche y costel a
cuando madera de mar se convirtió en un
concierto y björk con el pecho abierto
me ayudaba a improvisar y ya voy a
terminar esta primera ensalada porque si
no entienden nada de las cosas que
improviso le pido a todos permiso para
acabar mejor nada
primera ensalada
con la primera parte de los ponentes que
disfruta muchísimo claro
muchas gracias yo decía que en cuba sí
en cuba se enteran de que yo he venido
acá a improvisar bebiendo agua y no ron
me quitan el carnet de repentistas no me
dejan volver entrar a la isla espero que
esto quede entre nosotros
y si se entera que además voy por ahí
improvisando a capella y hablado también
entre un problema porque esto se hace
cantado y como acompañamiento
instrumental las controversias de los
guajiros en el campo y aunque yo no soy
del campo heredé de mi padre esta
tradición con mataron es corto como
javier rival
los pantalones me crecieron la
improvisación creo que también un
poquito y les voy a enseñar cómo se
canta en cuba como se puede cantar la
décima hay muchas variedades por una de
ellas es esta y dice así con la
con la torpeza de un hombre que se
levanta dormido
para mi segundo apellido
tras el primero y mi nombre
nunca falta quien se asombre
quien se burle o quién se ría pero no lo
cambiaría por 1 - risible porque es el
incorruptible guardián de mi poesía hay
quien piensa que sapos hay quien piensa
que es un hombre te mi apellido que
promete ponerle picante a todos
en mi apellido a como todo lo que me
alimenta y como me he dado cuenta que
así las cosas consigo a todo el que ande
conmigo
a todo el que ande conmigo
aquí también cuánticos
a todo el que ande conmigo le voy a
poner pimienta
eso un poquito de agua
muchas gracias
en cuba en cuba hay un refrán que dice
que si no hay pan que sabe el que sabe
era el pan de los indígenas antes de la
llegada de colón y se quedó como refrán
popular que cuando no hay pan casarse
así no hay ron hay tomas agua y te
sientes como si tuvieras en la patria
traído de agua
vamos con la segunda ensalada
pensará de los de la segunda parte
lo segundo exponentes
y a ver cómo queda esta vamos a alinear
destacó un poquito más de pimienta
dice
después
de haberme bebido un sorbito de agua
fría
veré si la poesía gana en mayor
contenido en lirismo sostenido en otra
forma de ser inescrutable hay que ver si
aquí la improvisación se mueve como un
fotón entre el mañana y ayer
espejo convencional repite me donde
estoy y dime por fin si voy o no voy
hasta el final porque yo sé que es igual
que ese rayo reflejado del poema
improvisado en esta región atlántica
tenga mecánica cuántica que yo no había
pensado
rayo láser o fotón ayúdame a hacer yo
mismo que es improvisa el repentismo el
espín del electrón que en toda mi este
esta actuación nadie crea que el
lenguaje es un juego de espionaje porque
yo puedo crecer y más tarde componer con
palabras el paisaje o puedo incluso
ponerme tan kiss
con esta belleza
con un sirope de fresa
y yo igual de quise hacer me puedo
incluso yo moverme como si fuera una
jaca
es verdad que esta no es flaca no es la
jaca de diseño de alguien a quien yo le
enseño mi poesía alharaca de poeta
repentista que dibuja una madonna y que
viene en esta zona a saber que es un
artista que ha pintado con la vista
algún gato de rosado
más no importa acostumbrado a mirar el
gato rosa puedo hacer aquí otra cosa que
también hoy me ha inspirado dejo mi
disfraz de hortera
y comienzo ahora a escuchar a christina
ya a cristina ya encantar y esto se hace
primavera esa muchacha extranjera que es
rubia como los trigos y que va buscando
amigos a través de una guitarra y que el
alma de samarrá y los pone como usted de
testigos de que si se pierde un tren se
encuentra un amigo nuevo y entonces
llega el relevo de la luz a cada cien y
yo la escucho también sentado en aquel
rincón viva la equivocación de trenes en
el destino que va tejiendo un camino de
emoción de remoción porque claro si yo
fuera testigo de aquel encuentro
me haría un ser fin por dentro para
verla a ella por fuera
porque es la única manera de volverse
repentista en vez de ser narcisista y el
palo de xerfi en alto y dejar sobre el
asalto la rima que me conquista la
máscara del ponent ella me la voy a
quitar para poderme abrazar de repente
de repente cara de pato
esta gente está viendo que el mulato ha
puesto cara de pato
la cara de un pato negro lo importante
es que me alegro y yo mismo me contrató
para en las redes sociales poner una
foto mía dar la cara a todo el día y
ustedes son tan geniales que en sitios
espirituales mirando su inteligencia
comparto la co presencia como decía
lucía con presencia cara mía público
gran concurrencia en esta foto han
salido pavos con muy buena cara estas
fotos le declaran lo que en el pecho he
traído y me encuentro conmovido porque
yo soy un poeta que me traje una chuleta
igual que javier ruibal y ya ven llegué
al final hice la rueda completa yo no
tuve una guitarra ni a con un hermano
mayor que quiso ser tocador y me dejaba
en la barra del silencio en cada farra
como mis cortos pantalones no tuve por
los rincones que curtir la inteligencia
con esa desobediencia que tú das en tus
canciones por mccartney no me ha visto
ni me ha invitado a cantar pero yo puedo
rimar pues como si fuera alguien listo
aprender que no soy cristo pero puedo
resolver esos problemas de ayer en el
ahora ahora mismo y aprender con
repentismo también a no obedecer porque
oyendo tus canciones amigos javier
ruibal quien no quiere que al final les
salgan tantos fotones y líricos
electrones que contamine a la gente y
que en cualquier continente pueda haber
un repentista que se vuelva guitarrista
del puerto que es diferente puerto de
santamaría
puerto de santamaría
puerto de santamaría cuando se tiene a
un javier cuando se tiene un javier que
se pone a componer en estambul cualquier
día y que recorre la vía del tiempo del
agua dado no se puede estar callado en
una silla escondido cuando le llega al
oído las cosas que él ha contado por eso
agradezco tanto que me hayan hecho
versar y ponerme a improvisar frente a
alguien que me agigantó si lo veo y me
suplantó si no lo veo y lo miro y lo
respeto y lo admiro por eso yo soy
cubano y le voy a dar la mano que esas
cosas de guajira
[Risas]
[Aplausos]
segundo estará muy bien
muy bien
la tercera ensalada es la que más me
gusta porque es la que ustedes digan de
ser comensales pasivos y comienzan a
hacer
comenzar es activos comensales
y ahora voy a pedirle ayuda a charo que
me haga la asistente para que ustedes me
dicen las palabras de esta ensalada esta
ensalada vamos a hacer con las palabras
que ustedes sobre lo que ha pasado aquí
las palabras que ustedes quieren
destacar y con esa ella las va apuntando
me da la lista y hacemos la tercera
ensalada de jornada con las palabras
ustedes quieren comenzamos con el huevo
primera palabra
luz
segunda palabra
como emoción puede ser palabras y
personajes personajes literarios
históricos musicales pictóricos
filosóficos
corazón estás haciendo la décima tuvo
emoción corazón si después de luna dice
andaluz debajo del escenario
agradecimiento
hembra
chipirones y chipirones bien estaba
comiendo es algo que editan
lo las flores
alicia gambas
la ensalada se va poniendo ya con más
cuerpo como came la canela
inés rosales
keys e inés rosales x haber nutria
nutria
jamaica
como flamenca malecón alguna más
superposición
que no falte
[Aplausos]
y la última guaguancó que llegó para que
rincón guaguancó a mascarpone un
voluntario que me encantan los
voluntarios me encanta como la gente
trabaja ahí va al asistente por ahí va
bajo la nutria
[Risas]
bueno lo que termina de copiar me las
palabras decides eso que cuando oiga muy
poca gente
supón supongo que aquí también había
oído hablar de la palabra repentismo
antes de la palabra repentistas hay
muchos improvisadores en todo el mundo
con distintos nombres en el cono
suramericano los payadores de argentina
uruguay y chile los huapangueros de
mexico los cantaores de cantores de
mejorana de panamá repentistas en cuba y
en brasil
si nos vamos a españa los regueifeiros
gallegos los versos lares vascos los
troveros de andalucía y de murcia los
versadores de canarias sino vamos a
italia los cantautores de toscana
los improvisadores del monte tus ardo en
cerdeña todas son formas de
improvisación poética con distintas
estrofas distintas melodías distintos
nombres distintos instrumentos pero todo
eso pertenece a un mismo un corpus
artístico digamos que tiene siglos de
desobediencia siglos de supervivencia
artística muchas veces a espaldas de las
instituciones y de la academia y de mí
sobre todo del gran aparato de los
poderes culturales prácticos
vamos allá sin verso de transición les
voy a decir los ingredientes que ustedes
han puesto en esta tercera ensalada luz
emoción corazón agradecimiento rembrandt
chipirones alicia gambas camel a lola
flores nutria flamenca malecón
superposición inés rosales guaguancó
jamaica agua que bajan adelante en la
penúltima y guaguancó
hacemos otra vez el juego imaginario nos
vamos nos vamos a cuba
todos viaje a cubas rápidos y
baratísimos
me encanta
dice
esta tercera ensalada
tiene mejor condimento
tiene mejores alimentos
a mí no me costó nada a copiarla
ya redactada una agenda me la han dado
las palabras
son recados del público que me mira y
esta 10ª guajira es el último pecado de
un poeta que improvisa con los verbos de
la gente que improvisa de repente que
hace sin tener la tiza una escritura y
divisa a través de la escritura es ahora
la literatura que venía del ayer y que
empieza a componer con diáfanas con
velocidad soltura como la luz de la
mente que atraviesa este salón como un
rayo de emoción que me toca de repente
en el corazón se siente cuando yo en
este momento dictó el agradecimiento a
la gente que me invita que rembrandt me
necesita para pintar el presidente que
sin mí no pinta bien que necesita el
pintor algún improvisador que mujer que
mujeres dedo ensucien y empiece a pintar
también los diferentes rincones y un
plato de chipirones para a rembrandt hay
que dar porque el real descubierto el
mar en gaditanos rincones sí no
prueba al momento un chip iron gaditano
y alicia le da la mano
rembrandt se pone contento que haya
gambas yo presiento que también le han
de gustar y que las pueda probar aquí
donde se sincera esa trabaja y se canela
a todo el que viene actuar puede ser que
lo las flores
en xerez se diera cuenta de que ha
venido pimienta a alimentar los señores
y pida a otros cantaores que vengan a
este lugar y que se ponga a escuchar una
nutria por ahí
y que diga estoy aquí yo quiero
participar y que esa nutria que sea
flamenca igual que la lola y que hable
lengua española y que comprenda esta
idea cuando improvisar me vea tomando
agua en vez de ron me recuerde el
malecón y me diga en el futuro no vas a
tocar el muro ni con superposición
porque estás en los locales de la tierra
gaditana en muy muy lejos de la habana y
comiendo inés rosales yo creo que esos
mentales
esos mentales enredos que estás haciendo
ni en jamaica se están viendo ni en
jamaica pueden verse y tendrían que
ponerse de acuerdo los que quienes
tejiendo van los test de vex por el
mundo de que pueda el hombre hacer un
guaguancó y comprender que ese baile
profundo en ese baile iracundo en ese
baile africano en el suelo gaditano
cuando el poeta trabaja baja baja baja
baja con una agenda en la mano y si
bailo guaguancó y si a jamaica me va me
voy y si puedo cantar hoy como lo
improviso yo en el rosal es medio la
dulzura que tenía superposición habría
que poner en un rincón y la
superposición la pongo mi poesía el
malecón me ha mirado y aquellas nutrias
flamencas que sabe que en una cuenca de
poema improvisado cabe lo que en el
pasado las flores me pidió entonces me
camelo alguien que no me camelas y las
gambas las pinedas las contamina
quien no se contamina muy bien con una
gamba vienes ya y alicia graba esta
fecha para que vengas también los
chipirones de quien me dictó los
chipirones puede ser que en los rincones
donde rembrandt no pintado tenga un
verso improvisado que me llene de
emociones bayas mi agradecimiento a todo
el que me dictó las palabras que ahora
yo estoy leyendo en el viento y me
siento tan contento que la luz me da en
la frente y yo puedo de repente
derrochar mucha emoción por ponerme el
corazón al servicio
muchísimas gracias señores
muchas gracias hola
muchas gracias
un honor
[Música]
muchas gracias de verdad un honor y una
fiesta para mí
participar en una fiesta de la
inteligencia como ésta chau muchas
gracias
[Música]